hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Abraham is the central figure in fear
and trembling why is that the case
because he illustrates for us what faith
means what it's import is not just for
the religious person but even for a
philosophical perspective that is
adequately open to it as Kierkegaard
depicts himself as being through his
narrator here and there's a lot of ways
to get the story of Abraham wrong as he
will will tell us by way of illustration
the question that is raised for us in
the early parts of this work is what do
we have to do to adequately understand
as far as we can
the Abraham's story and Kierkegaard
tells us that we have to put in work we
have to make some sort of commitment it
cannot be a merely as he's going to call
it a little bit later in the work
aesthetic attitude towards it so this
ties in with his remarks about the world
of the spirit and the work that we have
to do there he says that the story of
Abraham is remarkable in that it's
always glorious no matter how poorly
it's understood but here it's a matter
of whether or not we're willing to work
and be burdened and he says that his
current generation is unwilling to work
and yet they want to understand the
story he says we glorify Abraham but how
we recite the whole story in cliches so
let's actually look at some of these
cliches that can be useful the great
thing was he loved God in such a way he
was willing to offer him the best that's
true but the best is a vague term he
says mentally and orally we homologies
Isaac and the best and the contemplate
ur can smoke his pipe while koja tating
and the listener may stretch out his
legs comfort a
what's the problem with that why not
take in a story that way well we're not
getting at the real meet the core of the
story if we do that we turn Abraham into
this distant figure who had good
intentions and we don't consider it
really that closely and we can do the
same thing with all sorts of other
religious figures as well as we'll see
in the first probe LaMotta where
Kierkegaard is going to use the same
language to talk about for example Mary
and Jesus what's getting emitted what is
getting left out what would be involved
in the work that we have to put in
Kierkegaard tells us in this preliminary
expectoration that it's anxiety so he
says what is emitted from Abraham's
story is the anxiety to money I have no
ethical obligation but to the son the
father has the highest and the holiness
so we forget about that and we talk and
in the process of talking interchange
the two terms Isaac and the best and
everything goes just fine and then he
says okay imagine a case of a guy who's
sitting there in Sunday school or in the
pews listening to a sermon about about
Abraham and he says oh so Abraham was
willing to sacrifice Isaac to God
because Isaac was the best thing I
should have a child so I can go and
sacrifice that child that would like
really get me in good with God or lucky
me I've already got a child let's go and
do that and and if somebody said that we
would say no no no no you totally
misunderstood the story my friend don't
do that if you do it you're a terrible
person you're a murderer and Kierkegaard
says we could have the most you know
profound tragic and comic
misunderstanding if the preacher would
found out about this he would muster his
ecclesiastical dignity
and shout you despicable man you scum of
society what devil is so possessed here
that you want to murder your son and the
man could respond well wait a second
what about this Abraham's story so it
should be an uncomfortable story for us
and if that's the case we were already
starting to put in some of the work it's
wanting to push away the discomfort and
say oh you know God was God never really
meant for Abraham to take it so serious
he was just testing his faith or we say
well you know in this one case it was
okay we don't have any explanation for
why that would be but just don't murder
anybody in other cases we make the story
superficial and we lose the real core
that's available to us there that should
in fact place us in anxiety as
Kierkegaard is saying why he's going to
go on and tell us that there's a
contradiction that should be staring us
in the face involved in this story this
should not be a story that we tell to
satisfy people's doubts or to dispel
worries this should be a story that we
tell precisely because it problematizes
faith because it tells us that we don't
understand things as well as we would
like to think we do and in this section
the preliminary expectation he only
talks about anxiety later in the probe
LaMotta he's going to talk about anxiety
distress and paradox as all being
involved with in this abraham and isaac
story he's choosing these terms for a
good reason and they're not all
equivalent to each other there you might
say three interconnected aspects of the
same basic challenge or a comportment
that that we are facing
so why why anxiety he goes on and he
says there's a contradiction here a
fundamental contradiction one that we
can't argue away one that we can't just
resolve by saying oh just have faith and
the contradiction is going to be taken
care of no that would be rather circular
because the contradiction stems from the
very act of faith that the paradigmatic
example of faith that is Abraham is
presenting to us so what is the
contradiction
he says the ethical expression for what
Abraham did if we want to think about
this in terms of not just morality but
in terms of the highest values that we
can discuss and compare with each other
the values that are commensurate the
entire range of the ethical if we think
about it in that way Abraham is a
murderer
Abraham intends or means to murder Isaac
the fact that he does so at the command
of God doesn't actually make it better
or make him not a murderer and in some
respects it may may even make it worse
if I go and I murder my neighbor because
my neighbor is a serial killer and will
go out and kill again
that's a bad thing to murder somebody
but it could in fact be demanded of me
ethically if the only way that I can
stop this terrible person from
committing more crimes is to kill him
Isaac is an innocent Isaac is the person
that Abraham is supposed to love most
and he takes him ties him down to an
altar and pulls out a knife
preparing to slit his throat so from an
ethical standpoint Abraham is a murderer
and we shouldn't follow that example we
should say this is a terrible act it
would be terrible just as much as some
parent drowning his or her
child in a bathtub because they're poor
and in despair and think that life ahead
of that child is just going to be
suffering it's just as terrible as
somebody walking down the street and
grabbing a person at random and slitting
their throat what about from the
religious side he goes on he says the
religious expression of what Abraham is
doing is that Abraham means to sacrifice
Isaac and what what is sacrifice mean it
means that we well there's two ways to
see it one is sacrifice is merely an
economy of I give so I get in exchange
that's the way that many ancient people
and many modern people view sacrifice I
sacrifice for my child's welfare working
two jobs saving as much as I can not
enjoying myself so I can send my child
off to a good college so that I can
hound my kid the rest of his or her life
and say where is my payoff that's a very
trivial notion of sacrifice that is not
a religious notion of sacrifice that is
a commercial notion of sacrifice a
religious notion of sacrifice when it is
genuinely religious and not just a means
of commerce with whatever one takes to
be the gods involves taking what one has
that is best the first fruits an animal
one's own passions that are leading one
to violate the laws and destroying them
sacrificing them for something that is
higher to realize some sort of higher
value the Covenant in this case with
with God the relationship with God now
there's a question should Isaac be an
object of sacrifice generally for the
the biblical God no as a matter of fact
the neighboring peoples sometimes
engaged in that sort of thing and God
says don't do that sort of thing but he
tells Abraham to do that so we have a
contradict
here he says precisely in this
contradiction is the anxiety that can
make a person sleepless and yet without
this anxiety Abraham is not who he is
now that is a great phrase Abraham is
not who he is without this anxiety
Abraham himself is not some dummy he was
actually a clan leader he was able to
you know move from a civilized City
existence out into the wilderness he had
some brains this guy he actually manages
to argue with God and to bargain God
down almost successfully saving the city
of Sodom from divine vengeance so
Abraham is actually a very intelligent
person he would have known about what
was going on and that there's this moral
and ethical quandary that he's in and
that would place him in anxiety so
without having anxiety in the story
we're losing sight of Abraham but it
should also place us in anxiety as well
that's part of the work of striving to
understand the Abraham story this should
not just be something at a distance this
should be something that poses a problem
for us now a little bit later on I'd
mentioned that Kierkegaard is going to
connect anxiety distress and paradox in
the probe LaMotta and he tells us that
the paradox can be understood in several
different ways one is that the single
individual places himself in an absolute
relation to the absolute and we'll talk
about that at greater length later but
he says we do not want to know anything
about the anxiety the distress the
paradox we carry out an aesthetic
flirtation with the result it arrives
just as unexpectedly but also just as
effortlessly as a prize in a lottery and
when we've heard the result
we've built ourselves up we've edified
ourselves
this is a way of misunderstanding the
story it may be helpful when thinking
about this about this anxiety to
consider the other stories the other
people who Abraham brings up rather who
Kierkegaard brings up in this this
account so where else does this catch
phrase anxiety distress paradox come up
he talks about Mary the one who bears
Jesus a young woman who is inhabiting a
society we're having a child out of
wedlock
could in fact get you killed
and God comes to her and says hey you
are going to bear this child and she's
how's that gonna happen I haven't known
any man God says I'll take care of it
and she says yes she is sense and then
of course there's the happy story of
Joseph marries her and you know we have
the Christmas crash but if you think
about what that was like at the time
that would have been incredibly anxiety
provoking that would have been
incredibly distressful there would have
been a paradox several paradoxes perhaps
even involved there and Kierkegaard goes
on and says Mary bore the child
wondrously she did it after the manner
of women and such a time as one of
anxiety distress and paradox the angel
was a ministering spirit but he was not
a meddlesome spirit who went to the
other maidens in Israel and said don't
scorn at Mary the extraordinary is
happening to her the angel went only to
Mary and no one could understand her the
Mary's story
can be understood like the Abraham story
he goes on as well and he says about the
stories in the Gospel he says we're
touched we look back to the
beautiful times sweet sentimental
longing leads us to the goal of our
desire to see Christ walking around in
the promised land we forget the anxiety
the distress the paradox was it such a
simple matter not to make a mistake was
it not terrifying that this man walking
around the others was God
was it not terrifying to sit down to eat
with him was it such an easy matter to
become an apostle so he's not saying
that Jesus himself would have had the
anxiety distress in paradox although we
do see that in the biblical accounts at
certain points he did in fact incur that
but think about the disciples making
sense out of this guy who speaks with
authority in such ways who grew up as a
carpenter's son in some backwater you
know half Greek town what would you do
in that circumstance so when we
understand Abraham in this way we're
opening ourselves up to a possibility of
getting a lot more out of the story and
we can relate it to our own lives where
we may be encountering the anxiety the
distress and the paradox
you